this video was made possible by class
central which lets you watch tens of
thousands of lectures from the best
universities in America and around the
world from the comfort of your own home
check it out by clicking the link below
this video our pseudo science mini
series now brings us to extrasensory
perception or ESP which is an umbrella
term to describe any kind of acquisition
of information through means other than
the established physical senses seeing
hearing smelling tasting and touching
someone claims to have ESP when they
tell us that they're able to sense
things outside their body through some
means other than these five senses so an
example would be telepathy sensing
another person's thoughts clairvoyance
sensing events in another location
precognition seeing the future retro
cognition seeing things in the past that
you didn't witness or mediumship which
would be communicating with the dead or
knowing things about the spirits of dead
people some people call ASP a sixth
sense a psychic is someone who claims to
have one or more types of ESP and we
deal with psychics in another episode of
the mini series there's a 2016 report
from Ibis world which says that 85
thousand people in the united states
work as psychics collectively earning
about two billion dollars a year and
there's a 20-17 YouGov poll which says
that a fifth of Americans have consulted
a psychic in their life and that more
than a third of Americans have
personally experienced psychic ability
in themselves at least one time a
quarter of Americans also say that they
can supernaturally predict the future
and 38% say that they have sensed the
presence of a spirit during their life
without these numbers you might not
realize how relevant this pseudoscience
mini-series is you might see these
videos on different pseudo-sciences and
think who cares only wacky people
believe this stuff but no the numbers
are stunning and many people have no
idea how pseudoscience pervades our
society so in a 2014 study in the
scientific journal
one adults were shown before-and-after
photos of the same woman for a second
and a half sometimes they were the same
photo sometimes something was changed
about the woman maybe the color of her
hair whether she was wearing glasses
maybe her earrings changed the people
being tested were asked if the pictures
were the same or different and if they
noticed a difference they were asked
what the difference was mostly people
could correctly identify when there was
a change and when there wasn't but
what's interesting about the results was
that people were able to detect the
change even when they weren't able to
cognitively and consciously identify and
express what the change was and when the
participants were informed of the
results the fact that they were able to
detect changes even without being able
to explain what they were some of the
participants believed that they had some
kind of ESP because they intuitively
knew that something about the photo had
changed but they couldn't quite put
their finger on it and they said well
the reason is some kind of extrasensory
perception one of the study's co-authors
said quote people are correct in
believing that they have an ability to
sense changes in their environment even
when they cannot verbally identify what
those changes are it is just that this
ability is not a quasi magical Sixth
Sense it can be explained in terms of
known processes and this is a major
theme in pseudoscience humans want to
explain what they don't understand
often by any means necessary you might
not be conscious of what you're
perceiving so you might interpret your
correctness as something supernatural
there's a 2008 study at Harvard which
used brain scans to test whether people
claiming to have ESP were actually
acquiring knowledge that couldn't be
explained through some kind of normal
perception before the study scientists
already knew through neuroscience that
the brain responds a certain way when it
sees something familiar and a different
way when it sees something new before
the subjects were brain scanned they
were shown a bunch of pictures by way of
so called ESP what I mean by that is the
scientists would display the photos on a
computer screen in another another
for example or they would show the
photos to the subjects relative or
partner or friend in a different room
they displayed it in a number of other
ways that someone with ESP might claim
could get them to sense the image
without actually seeing it then they put
them in an fMRI brain scanner and showed
them the same pictures mixed with new
pictures that hadn't yet been used not
only could the subjects not identify
which pictures were new with any
statistical significance but their
brains responded the same way to every
photo responding the way a brain would
respond if it had never seen any of the
photos these studies aren't the full
extent of all research into ESP claims
but it's a sample of how we can actually
test some of these claims all the time
people report unexplained knowledge
having a dream where something happens
and the next day it happens in real life
or you were thinking about someone and
the very next moment you get an email
from them a dream or a feeling coming
true can seem or feel too amazing to be
a coincidence but not when you think
about it like a statistician you spend
your entire life constantly thinking
feeling and dreaming and every once in a
while some of those thoughts and
feelings line up with actual events it
would actually be more amazing if it
never happened much of the time it's
your brain putting things together
without you realizing it many
psychological processes go into what
makes up our intuitions and the
subconscious inferences we make every
day we aren't fully conscious of all the
perceptions we have and were rarely
conscious of what our brain does with
the information
nothing has proven that anything beyond
our five senses along with our conscious
and subconscious minds are formulating
these intuitions and in fact to the
contrary there's a lot of evidence
showing that our normal senses are
actually what inform us when we think
that we're using ESP many people who
call themselves psychics or mediums or
clairvoyance probably do believe that
they have special abilities
some of them are also consciously
fraudulently using cold reading
techniques to improve their predictions
analyzing someone based on what you
already know about them whether it's
their age their clothing their body
language or other characteristics
experiments and studies have failed many
times to prove the existence of ESP
which is a major issue if you're trying
to claim that it's real but that doesn't
prove it's not real which is what gets
us to another problem with ESP and lots
of pseudo-sciences which is that they
are unfalsifiable you can't prove that
ESP definitively does not occur as
skeptics this is when our BS detector
should go off right there's no
experiment or observation that could
disprove ESP so by definition the claim
that ESP is real cannot be a scientific
claim evaluated scientifically or
empirically it's effectively a claim
that is of no use to anyone in the real
world
who cares about evidence some who
believe in ESP might say claims about
ESP aren't supposed to be scientific
because it's by its nature supernatural
and therefore it's not even fair to
subject ESP to the type of empirical
scrutiny that one might want this would
be nonsense because ESP supposedly
interacts with the physical world we're
talking about having visions or
perceptions about what's happening in
material reality so it should be easy to
prove the accuracy of ESP if it were
actually accurate and at this point it's
unclear what kind of a conversation we
can even really have about that element
one of the biggest push backs against
ESP is common sense combined with what
we already know scientifically about the
natural world especially about vision
hearing neuroscience psychology physics
how could the ESPY possibly work it's a
difficult question for believers in ESP
to answer but if you want real
scientific answers about how the human
mind and intuition work check out some
of the excellent psychology lecture
video
over at class central class central
offers tens of thousands of University
courses on psychology and virtually any
other subject you can imagine you can
click the link in the description to
start searching for top-rated college
lectures from world-renowned
universities they've got everything
business science math computer
programming politics economics you'll
find something you'll love and tons of
courses are 100% free check it out at
class
- central.com slash Pakman or just click
the link under this video